The terrorist group ISIS is losing. At the
end of 2014 they claimed a territory the
size of Great Britain and a population
of 11 million people. But today it's lost
about 60% of that and its population is
down to about two and a half million.
It's the result of fighting its enemies
on all sides.
To the west and north, ISIS is fighting armed rebel groups and the Russian-backed Syrian military and it's allies.
It's also fighting Turkish troops and US-backed Kurdish forces in the north.
And to the east and south, there's the US backed Iraqi army. It was this Iraqi
army that delivered the latest blow when
they took over Isis's biggest city Mosul.
The group's capital in Iraq. It was a
symbolic loss. Mosul is where the group
declared a Caliphate, or Islamic
territory, in 2014. This set them apart
from other terrorist organizations. They
weren't just a network of jihadists
strung out across several countries like
Al Qaeda. They governed actual territory
which they called the Islamic state. Now
with the loss of Mosul, the fall of this
ISIS Caliphate seems imminent. So what
happens when Isis is gone?
Problem number one is that these fighters are going to want to go home. So in 2014 when
ISIS captured a huge swath of territory
in Iraq and Syria, tens of thousands of
foreign fighters came from all over the
world to join the caliphate.
According to UN estimates as of July
2016 there are upwards of 30,000 foreign
fighters. So most of these fighters came
from countries like Tunisia, Morocco,
Jordan, Saudi Arabia, but hundreds also
came from countries like Belgium, Germany,
the UK, and even a few dozen from the
United States. So these fighters were
drawn to ISIS for all sorts of different
reasons, but a big one was that it had
actual territory and was supposed to be
building a Caliphate based on its own
extreme interpretation of Islamic law.
ISIS propaganda pushed this narrative in
flashy violent videos and magazines
online encouraging people from all walks
of life, not just fighters, to come and
help build this glorious Islamic state.
And the people who came were not just
young men, they weren't just fighters,
there were women children and even
families who came as well. But now as
ISIS territory shrinks and the state
that they tried to build collapses,
anyone who survives will have to find
somewhere else to go... and that's a major
problem because many of these people are
now indoctrinated, there now
well-connected and they're capable of
carrying out deadly terror attacks.
A similar dynamic actually happened back in the 1980s in Afghanistan. So thousands
of foreign fighters flocked to
Afghanistan to help the Afghan mujahideen
fight the Soviet invasion.
After the Soviets left a lot of these
fighters dispersed to various different
theaters of jihad including Bosnia,
Chechnya, Somalia, Sudan, and elsewhere.
These fighters ended up forming a loose
network of transnational jihadists, most
of whom had links to Osama bin Laden and
al-Qaeda,
thanks to their time fighting in
Afghanistan. And some of them actually
went on to carry out attacks against the
West, including attacks against the
United States. So the worry now is that
ISIS fighters will do something similar
but this time they might actually make
it home to places like Europe and launch
attacks there.
So the second problem is what to do with the US military after
ISIS falls. Right now the US is helping
local forces in Iraq and Syria
to defeat ISIS. There are currently
around 1,000 US troops in Syria and
around 6,000 US troops in Iraq. Mosul
which was ISIS's capital in Iraq has
fallen and right now the US is helping
Syrian local forces to defeat ISIS in
Raqqa its so-called capital there. So as
those two cities fall ISIS has been
spreading out to rural areas. The Trump
administration had two choices. Option
one is to keep the US troops there which
would lead them in harm's way. Or option
two is to bring them home, which
increases the risk that the region
breaks out into war again. Option 1 is a
big political risk for Trump. He promised
during the campaign that he would not
get involved in foreign wars that he
would actually invest American money and
time and jobs and research in the United
States. And so if Trump were to keep
troops in the region it would be
admitting that he's going against the
political philosophy he espoused during
the campaign and currently during his
presidency. Option two is definitely also
a risk for Trump if US troops were to
leave that opens a space for sectarian
violence to break out in the region.
Let's take a look for example at what
happened in 2011 the Obama
administration took most of its troops
out of the region that gave the Shiite
government in Baghdad the space to crack down on Sunni population throughout the
country and ISIS took advantage of that.
ISIS was seen as the defender against
the Shiite government and was able to
gain support and allow for its rise.
So while it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's troops leave an ISIS type
group or ISIS 2.0 itself would grow out of
that absence of US troops but that risk
certainly exists.
A deadly California
shooting rampage. A lone gunman to pledge allegiance to ISIS. Both incidents
carried out by so-called lone wolves
Problem number three is ISIS moving from a place to an idea. Up until now ISIS had
one goal: defend the territory it already
had in Iraq and the territory already
had in Syria. The problem is on the verge
of losing both. When that happens
ISIS goes from being the kind of place
people go to fight to being the idea
that people fight for.
It's an idea that's compelling it's an
idea that its followers are willing to
kill for and as followers are willing to
die for. When they first came to power
people thought it's a group that has its
own territory, it wants to control that
territory, but it's not al-Qaeda, it's not
a terror group that wants to carry out
attacks outside of its borders in the
West. That was proven tragically wrong in
October of 2015.. "this is the bomb ISIS
claims they use to bring down the
Russian passenger plane over the Sinai
Peninsula." In their online magazine they
posted photos of the bomb that they said
had been used to blow up the plane. And
that was a reminder for was about to
come. A wave of ISIS attacks that have
killed hundreds of people in London, in
Paris, and in Nice. And have inspired
attacks that have killed dozens here at
home in California and in Orlando. It's
worth remembering that these are not
always attacks carried out by people who
are part of ISIS. In many cases these are
people who are radicalized in the
countries where they lived and that's
the danger of the idea. Take what
happened in San Bernardino, California
where a married couple killed 14 people.
Or in Orlando where a single shooter
killed 49 people. In both cases ISIS
claimed responsibility but in both cases
there is no connection between those
people and Isis. They got radicalized
over the Internet
Isis has known that propaganda matters
and ISIS is really good at it. It has
people all over the world who use English
language Arabic language to have
Facebook pages and Twitter accounts that
are full of incredibly slickly produced
videos. They're really compelling and if
you're someone predisposed to have that
worldview, they can push you over the
edge from just thinking that's an idea
worth killing for,
to actually killing for it. ISIS takes it
so seriously
that it refers to these people as media
operatives and says those media
operatives are carrying out a form of
martyrdom akin to killing, to literally
killing for the cause. And at the end of
the day that's the hardest thing about
ISIS. It can be beaten
on the ground in Iraq and Syria. It is
being beaten on the ground in Iraq and
Syria, but it's going from being a place
to an idea. And it is impossible,
impossible to defeat an idea.